for untold millennia the great
rainforests of Central America have been
kept alive by one of the Tiny's and
least understood of creatures but now
their fragile world has been invaded by
an alien species from Africa the result
of a scientific experiment gone horribly
wrong one man entomologist David Rubik
believes he's imported African bees are
edging out the native honeybees and
damaging the rainforests he's searching
for evidence
at stake here is the future of the
rainforests of America's heart and soul
of the rainforest gleams of its
pollinators and the things that make all
the plants reproduce
it all started in Brazil in 1957
scientists were studying an aggressive
type of bee from Africa when a few of
them escaped it was a mistake
it would have enormous consequences
the African bees proved extremely
adaptable to their new home
their numbers soared and they form
voracious swarms that spread throughout
South America and up to the southwestern
United States easily agitated and quick
to attack they were dubbed killer bees
known to sting humans to death swarms
react faster than other honeybees and
had been known to chase victims for a
quarter of a mile the rubic says they
pose a far greater threat to the fragile
rainforests than they do to people this
is one of the millions
these bees have done something no other
bee ever good these things have sucked
up most of the resources that are out
there for bees and for other animals too
not just bees as it flowers for food
birds bats butterflies other things take
the same food
and it's not just here and there it's
really everywhere
all the fast tourist areas we think it
was absolutely wildlife preserves have
been violated by this fee this P doesn't
belong in any of them
it lives in all of them it's not going
to go away
can native South American honeybees
survive the onslaught of their killer
cousins
a Vanda native bee nest suggests it's a
losing battle
the disturbing reality is that it is not
a natural part of this community
yet it has become part of nature and
ironically man has put it there but man
can't take it away
no one knows if the native bees will
survive the alien onslaught or
ultimately perish but Rubik intends to
continue monitoring the fate of this
little matey it's been a staple of the
rain forest since the time of the aegis